let's jump to this next story we got a
story from variety uh luke rudkowski's
dad bill maher says woke baggage is
democrats biggest problem stop talking
about pregnant men man what a turnaround
first the important thing he's not
really luke's dad
yeah and vladimir putin is not luke's
uncle that's right none of that and
assange if all three of them had a dna
baby somehow i would pop out probably
but uh a few years ago
dennis prager goes on bill maher's show
and he's like they're claiming that men
can have periods and then bill maher is
like no they're not he's like yes they
are and they're putting tampons in the
men's room and bill maher is like oh
it's for their girlfriends you're crazy
now bill maher is coming out and saying
like stop talking about pregnant men
so maybe i guess i can bring this up
because
i think what happens with bill maher
is that he's kind of seeing the writing
on the wall he's like oh this weird cult
stuff is not popular and if we keep
embracing it we're going down so uh he
saw the writing on the wall he's
changing his tune and pushing back and
saying no to this i think this is a
white pill moment like we can talk about
the weirdo cult we can talk about
industry control but let's just say this
you got prominent hbo mainstream liberal
personality pushing back on wokeness
you've got independent artists gaining
traction expanding and pushing back on
the machine literally actually raging
against the machine and and succeeding
so i look at this like
the weirdo uniparty cult ain't working
out it's it's fizzling right and i think
a lot of it is because it lacks common
sense right and it almost feels like a
test
of how far what can we what can we
program these people to believe right
like if if you're starting to lose
common sense like it's obvious that men
can't get pregnant obvious it's it's
like
right come on but
it's almost like let's run this test to
see who we can convince this and what
part of people are convinced
convinceable to do anything right like
you have people that are that are
jumping onto this right those are the
people that are unreasonable those are
the people that that no matter what
facts you show that are currently going
on they will deny the facts you could
you could show them you know data from a
year later
they'll deny the data you could show
them oh you know men can't get pregnant
oh i don't believe that you don't need
to show them that i mean it's ridiculous
but it's crazy that's what i'm saying
it's like how far how far can we program
certain people it's almost like a test
it's almost like they're running they're
running tests to see how convincible
that's why i'm saying you know
simulation theory baby we are in a
computer simulation and there's someone
sitting there going like okay let's
enter the parameters and let's now
introduce telling all of the americans
that men can get pregnant i think
they're hacking 17 actually agreed with
that
they're hacking the way people think is
like darwin for instance would say it's
not the strongest of the species that
survives but the one that's most
adaptable to change and if people change
to believe psychosis
that's part of like we're able to do
that if we need to to survive for the
moment let's just pretend that eating
the frozen dead bodies we've crash
landed in the in the arctic let's
pretend like it's normal what everyone
get like you see that movie alive
that group went down they had to eat
each other to survive you know you just
put yourself in a moment of psychosis
we're like this is normal we're gonna
get through it and then
for better or worse you know we've
basically accepted something that other
you might normally think is psychotic so
i think people have hijacked that with
social media and they're feeding it and
they're like transit transiting people
or something that's what stalin said so
he he had plucked all the hairs off this
chicken right
and the feathers yeah all the feathers
yep thank you for that
so you're the chicken master i don't
have a chicken you know so so he he
tortured this chicken and then after
torturing the chicken gave it a little
food and then the chicken followed him
around for the rest of the day he's
hungry and he essentially says it's like
you could torture people you could
torture animals you could you could
torture something and if you just give
it a little more so it'll it'll come
back to you for more and i feel like
we're being conditioned right now to to
you know the financial crisis that we're
being conditioned that that oh inflation
could be at 80 percent 10 is not bad
we're being conditioned that we we oh
well you you know you want your own
apartment when you can't afford it well
just get two roommates like we're being
conditioned to like lower
understand
you know our standards of life like oh
you're working 40 hours a week you don't
have any money living in your car like
well there's a lot of people doing that
so you should be grateful that you're
not in the tent in portland like
do you see what david hogg said
so for those who don't you guys know
david hogg he's the he's one of the gun
control activist guys on twitter and he
said that he's not gonna have kids he'd
rather have a porsche or a portuguese
water dog and a lot of people saw that
tweet i retweeted it and they were and
you know i quote tweeted him and said
thank you for your sacrifice david
you're making the future a better place
you know but but you know it goes both
ways like fighting climate change hey
all right not having kids hey doubles
but here's here here's people missed his
first tweet in the thread
he said something like
children are the new luxuries and what i
mean is
it's something where you it's really
difficult to have you can't afford it so
it's nice when your friend comes by and
and shows it off but it's not for you
because you can't afford it it's like a
boat yeah children are like the modern
day boat that's what he said that's a
way to take happiness off people my
children are the greatest things that
happen in my life when i hear someone
you know
go to that extent to say like i'm not
gonna have kids like they're punching
themselves that that's him punching
themselves i love my kids so much it's
such a gift and
and it does it selfishly does so much
for me to have my kids because i get to
feel this this love and i get this bond
and this and this connection that i
think if that's the direction they're
gonna go are they gonna push everyone
into not having kids and not
experiencing that love and not being
able to spend time with family i think
that's a bad direction i think that's a
bad direction it's another direction
away from god it's another direction
into
the the the servitude yeah the servitude
the satanic ism it's this another
another way to suck love away from you
or suck
uh the the greatest things in life out
of your life it's just the biggest gift
denying it to yourself because of some
propaganda that you heard because some
elitist newspaper telling you that it's
bad for the environment which is
absolutely absolutely just an insane
thought and and just debunk on its basic
premise but but his point was it's like
a boat where it's like your friend has
one it's fun to go visit and see theirs
but not have one yourself and then he
says i'd rather have a portuguese water
dog he said what did he say he also said
something i mean these are interesting
points to be made
i don't i don't agree necessarily but
he's making interesting points that he's
uh he was basically saying
a pet is a cheaper it's cheaper than a
kid it reaches a certain point where
it's not going to get any more expensive
you've got to pay for college a house
plant is cheaper than a pet you get it
you have it you take care of it but he's
he's actually making a really great
point for people who want something to
take care of child is one of the hardest
things but one of the most rewarding i
mean you're on your death bed and you've
got a human being who loves and is
caring for you and making sure you're
comfortable on your way out a dog ain't
going to do that but a poor dog is
cheaper a dog is cheaper so instead of
spending you know i think it's like 250
000 to raise a kid or something you're
spending 10 000 on a dog maybe then you
can't even you can't even deal with that
level of taking care of something
because you've got to schedule letting
it out so you get a cat but then you
don't really you know maybe you can't
afford the cats to get a plant now the
plant is like the lowest level of caring
for a life form but they're also missing
a huge point of of what kids do to your
motivation as well most people will say
that raising kids are hard but once you
have your kids you're going to do
anything anything you have to do
to give them the best life and usually
you become a better person because of
those kids and you
you get motivated to to
to work harder make more money be a
better family man yeah and strengthen
your spirit too i'm telling you it
brings you closer to god you have kids
you you you feel some form of spiritual
power within yourself and connection to
it to another being that that helps you
up up your level man you level up and
it's you know i i walk around in my in
my 20s saying i'm never going to have
kids and and you know spoke like that
and then and then you learn and and i
would say for anyone that
feels like they don't need to have kids
i do think you miss out on on a bit of a
spiritual connection with god you miss
out on just a love that that is just
indescribable um and the people that are
gonna be by your bedside you know look
my father just passed away i love you
dad
and it was me my brother with him and my
mom it was us
yeah so uh we talked about this
about a lot of women
who are lying to themselves or are
scared to to to express themselves
the young turks it's it's remarkable how
they can like take what i say and then
completely ignore what i say but show
what i say and then turn into something
i didn't say
so i said basically i'm sure most women
are happy to have their jobs and their
success and more power to them i have
tremendous respect to anybody male or
female they want to get you know get a
job and succeed but i but i think there
are some women and a lot of them
that really do just want to have
families and not be breadwinners but are
worried about this because it's not so
not as socially acceptable anymore and
they're expected to have careers and
with the economy the way it is they have
to work so there's a lot of these women
that are either denying it they're lying
to themselves or they're too scared to
speak up but once they're older they're
going to regret it yeah they're going to
win now i'm not saying literally every
woman i'm not saying the majority of
women say there's just a lot of women
who are probably experiencing this so
take that out of context young jerks by
all means but i think it's true i think
i think the thing is for guys they can
have kids like this like 70 year old
dude can have a kid clint eastwood did
that i mean you got four million little
soldiers firing off in each each attempt
and only only one of them needs to be
viable i hear the woman's body decides
which sperm and implants the egg too
fertilizes the egg like adorable
magnetic
but you know everyone has a has a window
to you know um fertility men also as
well but not as severe as women that by
the age of 30 lose almost 90 percent of
all the eggs that they had throughout
their entire life in existence and even
talking about this it's a touchy subject
because people automatically get very
emotional but i think at the end of the
day there's a legitimate argument to
make that a lot of women have been
brainwashed to serve corporations rather
than of course their own families and i
think that's something that deserves to
be talked about deserves to be debated
and you know we could be wrong on this
particular topic but but again at least
let's have the conversation that's being
denied to everyone and having children
um is is something that gives a lot of
people purpose something that allows
people to have something greater than
themselves charles art levera he's a ufc
champion i love him he had a couple of
fights in his career he lost them he was
he won some but then he went on a streak
where he just dominated everyone he's
one of the best fighters right now in
the ufc and he attributes having a child
to him
being on a trajectory and on a purpose
that made him that much better than
almost everyone else in the division and
he's dominating he's one of the best
fighters that the ufc has ever seen and
he attributes that to having children so
that's a power there that i think is
worth tapping into yeah you just gotta
imagine the guy you're fighting is
trying to punch your kid yeah and then
you're just like invincible the other
guy is fighting for sport you're
fighting for your kid i mean even in all
seriousness you're fighting against
somebody who doesn't have kids and none
of them do but like you're fighting for
someone who's passionate driven by sport
you're driven by protecting your family
you're probably gonna have a leg up on
you know and then i'm reading the
comments here someone's telling me oh i
was gonna have my eggs frozen people
don't understand that that also leads to
a lot of problems and also has a very
big risk of of not working and you could
probably talk about this uh lydia
because i think you did some research
into this as well
oh i never looked at freezing my eggs
because i know that's not a good idea
but i have lots of friends who've done
ivf it's incredibly painful it's a
horrible process if you can avoid it you
should i think we need to emphasize
getting married and making families
younger but it's a cultural issue that i
don't know if we can change for the top
down we have to see what happens when
you were first having kids rick were you
was did you go through like a panic
state yeah of course it's it's everyone
goes through the same process right you
don't want you
you you almost fear yourself out of
having them and then i mean we watched
it happen with our guitar player like
one year before he's telling me like i'm
just not meant to have kids man and
ain't in my cars i don't want a blah
blah you know like the whole speech and
i'm like i don't know man like when you
i told him i said when you have a kid
you're going to think your kid's the
greatest that's all you're going to talk
about i don't think so
if i called him right now i'd be like
what do you what are you doing he's like
hanging on my little buddy he's the
greatest man
you gotta see him he's already played
dude he's already playing stairway to
heaven on the guitar he's one you know
like
like you you
like you said the the best sperm gets
into the door right so you're proud
you're pumped and and i uh you know what
luke you were saying i think that that
it's in it's in our it's embedded in
women it's embedded in us to have this
this
you know nature this this motherly
nature this fatherly instinct and i
think women are just so great
at
family and my wife is amazing at keeping
our family together and helping lee you
know helping me lead and make me a
better person and it's just family is is
so important
and i think that women are so good at it
that when when you're you see
corporations or whatever it may be
that's
making them not want to have kids or not
want to experience that they're they're
not experiencing something that they're
just so
great at they're just you know for for a
husband to watch my wife i'm just blown
away all the time
by her ability to be
uh so family oriented such a great
mother just so i could just sit here all
day but it's just a characteristic of
great women you know i used to say i
didn't want to have kids because unless
i could bring them around the world with
me i want to travel and go like how how
have you dealt with being on the road if
you when you tour with having kids if
you don't bring them along because i
don't know do you bring you i think we
talk before you so you don't bring them
along every time
i don't bring them along every time but
i just i know i got to provide for them
and that's very important and i know i
got to provide a good life and i think
the way our schedule is is i like it i
like going for two three weeks working
so hard with my best friends i'm going
to be with my best friends
it gives me another balance to my life
we have a great time together and then i
get to go home and be my kids and my
wife 24 hours a day i don't got to wake
up and show up to no job for eight hours
take an hour break when i get i get to
be with my family for two three months
straight all day every day and and the
juice is worth the squeeze to me so yeah
i missed them thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you